sur sensation
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans zone Europe
sur Radio sensation et sur TV 78 une
émission spéciale réalisée à Berlin
Berlin première ville de l'UE capitale
de l'Allemagne un pays membre de l'UE
depuis 1958 de l'espace Schengen depuis
1995 et qui a adopté l'euro le 1er
janvier 1999 à travers cette émission
nous allons vous parler de politique
d'environnement mais aussi de culture et
nous allons vous faire découvrir Berlin
zone Europe
rien qu'à Berlin on trouve plus de 2500
parcs et jardins l'environnement c'est
au cœur des préoccupations ici en
Allemagne et on va s'intéresser à la
place du développement durable dans la
formation professionnelle c'est un
projet soutenu par le fond citoyen
franco-allemand autour des bibliobox
vous savez c'est cabines téléphoniques
transformées en bibliothèque mana
mascary
je m'appelle Gary je suis secrétaire
d'État pour l'Europe au sein du
Département de la culture au Sénat de
Berlin
dont le projet des bibliobox depuis de
nombreuses années il existe des
nombreuses bibliobox réparties dans
toute la ville et il existe beaucoup de
coopérations internationales liées à ce
projet
j'ai moi-même voyagé à l'international
pour inaugurer des bibliobox l'idée est
de rendre la littérature accessible à
tous les habitants une ville et plus
largement à tous les Européens
les thématiques autour des bibliobox se
sont des sujets qui intéressent beaucoup
les gens en ce moment car elle
s'inscrivent dans le développement
durable
le plus longtemps possible avec des
matériaux pouvant être recyclés puis
réutilisés
et donc protéger le plus possible la
nature l'environnement est aujourd'hui
une thématique non seulement les
nationales mais aussi européenne
et l'Allemagne ce sont renforcés au fil
des années et l'exemple le plus concret
de coopération et celui du contrat
d'Aix-la-Chapelle sur la création d'une
assemblée parlementaire franco-allemande
c'est un exemple de coopération entre
les États membres de l'Union européenne
et un modèle de ce qui doit être fait
dans les écoles
que les cours brasseurs avec les
partenaires polonais mais ces exemples
peuvent être étendus à de nombreux États
membres de l'Union européenne
autre dossier d'actualité les ambitions
militaires de l'Allemagne la guerre en
Ukraine et la crise énergétique en
Europe on en parle avec Thomas veder il
est le correspondant du journal Le Monde
en Allemagne
zone Europe
bonjour Thomas Weber bonjour merci
d'être avec nous dans zone Europe alors
au moment où nous enregistrons cette
émission à Berlin l'actualité est marqué
par la crise énergétique qui touche
l'Europe c'est l'une des conséquences de
la guerre en Ukraine alors avant cette
guerre l'Allemagne recevait 55% de son
gaz en provenance de Russie via les
gazoducs norme stream notamment dans la
mer Baltique lieu à les 27 pays de l'UE
ont signé un accord récemment pour
réduire donc de 15% leurs importations
de gaz et leur consommation de gaz
notamment comment l'Allemagne va-t-elle
faire pour atteindre cet objectif alors
pour l'Allemagne c'est évidemment un
défi un défi considérable parce que vous
l'avez dit 55% de son gaz était importé
de Russie avant avant la guerre du crâne
ce qui en fait un des pays les plus
dépendants peut-être pas autant que
l'Autriche qui est importé 100 % mais
compte tenu de la taille et de
l'importance de l'Allemagne ce sont des
volumes considérables comment fait-elle
plusieurs réponses première réponse
d'abord diversifier ses
approvisionnements en gaz c'est ce
qu'elle a commencé à faire notamment en
important des hydrocarbures des de
Norvège et puis également des Pays-Bas
ça c'est la première la première réponse
ce qui fait que on est passé de 55% à
26% au mois de juin 26% du gaz
importé et vient de Russie donc
diversification d'un autre côté l'autre
réponse c'est diversification des
sources d'énergie parce que le gaz sert
en fait à différentes choses au
chauffage voilà mais aussi à la
production d'électricité donc
l'idée c'est de relancer d'autres
sources alternatives de production
d'électricité qui ne soient pas au gaz
donc c'est notamment la décision de
relancer les centrales à charbon qui a
été qui a été annoncé au mois de juin et
puis troisième volet qui ou l'Allemagne
finalement là-dessus rejoint les autres
les autres pays européens c'est l'idée
d'une sobriété énergétique des mesures
ont été annoncées
la mi-juillet par le ministre de
l'économie notamment demandant aux gens
de de moins se chauffer cet hiver enfin
bref un catalogue de mesure qu'on
retrouve dans dans d'autres pays mais je
pense que ce qu'il faut bien retenir et
vous avez eu raison de commencer par ça
c'est cet extrême dépendance de
l'Allemagne au gaz russe rend évidemment
la période extrêmement compliquée compte
tenu des des quantités qui sont en jeu
alors cette stratégie justement
énergétique donc elle ne date pas d'hier
Angela Merkel y est pour quelque chose
après critiquer ici en Allemagne
pourquoi
donc c'était délibéré de dépendre autant
de la Russie ou finalement l'Allemagne
n'avait pas le choix
n'avait pas d'autres opportunités elle
aurait pu avoir le choix mais je pense
que là il faut faire un petit point
d'histoire et remonter notamment aux
années 70 à l'époque on était pendant la
guerre froide l'Allemagne était divisée
en deux et le gouvernement de
l'Allemagne de l'Ouest sous vilibrante
social-démocrate avait eu cette idée qui
a profondément marqué la politique
extérieure allemande en gros on va dire
jusqu'à aujourd'hui quasiment jusqu'à la
guerre en Ukraine qui était ce qu'on
appelle lost politique c'est-à-dire
voilà l'Allemagne certes fédéral était
encré à l'ouest mais il fallait quand
même tendre la main au soviétique à
l'époque et l'idée était dans les années
70 que c'était peut-être en
améliorant nos relations avec avec
Moscou que
le régime soviétique allait se
libéraliser et peut-être à terme allait
arriver la réunification allemande la
réunification allemande est arrivée
l'Union soviétique s'est effondrée et
finalement l'idée après dans les années
90 début des années 2000 l'air lin puis
le début de l'air Poutine c'était de se
dire une version une vision très
mercantiliste des relations
internationales finalement nous notre
intérêt c'est de faire du commerce avec
les Russes d'importer des matières
premières et de leur vendre des produits
manufacturés mais derrière ça il y a une
expression en allemand qui s'appelle
Randle Randle c'est-à-dire le changement
par le commerce c'est à dire que c'est
en faisant du commerce que peut-être que
on avait
la Russie voilà c'était une sorte de
Paris géopolitique que l'Allemagne a
aussi fait un peu avec la Chine
d'ailleurs et puis qui donc l'a entraîné
à ce à se lier ainsi avec avec la Russie
sachant que par ailleurs
c'était une façon aussi d'avoir des
hydrocarbures bon marché pour pour
pour une industrie allemande en pleine
en pleine expansion et tout ça a
finalement fonctionné jusqu'à ce que ça
se fracasse sur la guerre en Ukraine
l'une des erreurs entre les cas qui a
fait la Merkel qui lui a été reproché
c'est pas seulement d'avoir continué
cette politique qui finalement remontait
comme je le disais aux années 70 mais
c'est aussi d'avoir en je crois en
2014-2015 au moment même alors même que
déjà la Russie avait attaqué le Dombas
c'est c'était emparé de la Crimée
d'avoir signé un contrat pour construire
un deuxième gazonique 2 qui lui est mort
né enfin il est le chantier est achevé
depuis l'année dernière mais il est
évidemment à l'arrêt c'est à dire en
quelque sorte d'avoir poursuivi cette
politique de dépendance énergétique
alors même que sur le plan géopolitique
les relations se compliquées avec un peu
compliqué et cette crise justement
énergétique elle intervient peu après
l'adoption en Europe du pacte vert
européen et donc pour contrer et pour
baisser les les importations de gaz
c'est éviter une pénurie vous l'avez dit
de l'Allemagne a relancé les centrales à
un charbon et c'est une décision en plus
prise par un gouvernement qui a les
écologistes en sont en son sein c'est un
peu un comble finalement est-ce que
l'Allemagne n'est pas coincé aujourd'hui
d'un point de vue environnemental vous
avez absolument raison il y a cette
décision sur les centrales à charbon qui
a été annoncé depuis il y a aussi la
relance des centrales à limite
c'est-à-dire un matériau encore plus
polluant que le charbon autre chose que
qu'on pourrait mentionner c'est le fait
d'aller chercher du gaz
à importer notamment des émirats du
Qatar le ministre de l'économie et de
l'énergie qui est un écolo un écologiste
Robert rabak est allé je crois au mois
de mars ou avril négocié un contrat
d'importation ce qui fait que
l'Allemagne est en train aujourd'hui de
construire des terminaux pour recevoir
du gaz naturel liquéfié sur la mer du
Nord et sur la mer Baltique ce qui était
complètement inenvisageable du point de
vue des Verts donc en gros on peut dire
qu'ils avalent beaucoup beaucoup de
couleurs en ce moment après
qui est intéressant je trouve c'est
qu'ils le font j'ai envie de dire à
l'allemande c'est-à-dire de façon assez
pragmatique
peut idéologique et ce ministre de
l'économie à bec sentir pas trop mal
disons sur le plan politique en
expliquant que il est coincé il y a pas
trop le choix que si l'Allemagne veut se
chauffer que si l'industrie allemande
veut continuer à tourner il faut bien
trouver des sources d'énergie
alternatives quand bien même elle serait
polluante quand bien même elle ne
correspondrait pas aux valeurs des vers
à côté de ça ce qu'il faut quand même
pas oublier c'est que et ça c'est fidèle
disons à l'engagement des verres et au
contrat de coalition qui a été négocié
l'an dernier après les élections
législatives et le départ de Merkel il y
a quand même derrière tout ça tout un
plan absolument considérable de
construction de de d'éolienne de enfin
tout tout le plan énergie renouvelable
qui lui rejoint ce que vous disiez le
pacte vert européen donc d'une certaine
façon à long terme enfin à terme
l'Allemagne
respecte ça ce qu'il y a c'est que là
elle est obligée de prendre des
décisions qui la font un peu sortir mais
je pense qu'elle est pas elle est pas
elle est pas la seule non plus à le
faire sur le plan militaire maintenant
au live Schulz a surpris tout le monde
le nouveau chancelier allemand lorsqu'il
a annoncé vouloir investir 100 milliards
d'euros dans l'armée allemande pour la
moderniser et la remettre à niveau c'est
une grandeur révolution on connaît les
Allemands aujourd'hui comme étant un
peuple très pacifique comment était
perçu comment était accueilli cette
nouvelle en Allemagne à part les deux
extrêmes l'extrême droite et l'extrême
gauche qui pour des raisons à la fois
semblables et différentes l'ont mal
accueilli semblables parce que des deux
côtés ce sont des parties qui l'orgue un
peu vers la Russie
différentes parce que côté extrême
gauche il y avait cette veine
effectivement pacifiste et
antimilitariste à part
c'est de ces deux forces politiques
l'ensemble du spectre politique c'est à
dire à peu près 60 70 %
de l'électorat allemand a accueilli
favorablement cette cette décision
l'accueil favorablement parce que y
compris les verres là aussi dans les
dans les dans les concessions tous les
couleurs à avalées par les Verts il y a
aussi l'idée de rhumatisme militariser
l'Allemagne un parti qui était quand
même
pacifiste enfin antimilitariste dans les
années 80-90 mais la chose a été plutôt
bien acceptée pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord parce que
je pense que il y a un vrai sentiment
quand même que la donne géopolitique est
en train de changer et que
ce dont on se rend pas forcément compte
quand on est à Paris ou à Marseille
c'est que mais mais qu'on sent ici à
Berlin à fortiori qui est vraiment à
l'est de la mettre c'est que la Russie
n'est pas loin la Russie n'est pas loin
les réfugiés Ukrainiens sont arrivés
auprès de 900 000 en Allemagne en
Allemagne donc cette
cette crise qui qui se produit elle est
très tangible et elle est
géographiquement elle est
géographiquement proche donc je pense
que ça joue quand même ce sentiment de
ce sentiment de menace la deuxième la
deuxième raison c'est que cela fait des
années que
alors même que déjà ce profil quand même
le fait que le monde change le
terrorisme d'un côté la montée de la
menace russe de l'autre la Chine qui
évolue on sait pas trop comment ça fait
des années que on sent que le monde
devient plus instable et que
alors même qu'il y a des réflexions voir
des demandes de la part de l'OTAN d'un
certain nombre de pays européens la
France ce que fait la France en Afrique
etc qui qui vont dans le sens de bon
voilà le militaire c'est quelque chose
de sérieux il faut se défendre face aux
menaces l'Allemagne était toujours un
peu en retrait et ça fait des années que
chaque année vous avez le rapport annuel
sur l'état de l'armée allemande de la
Bundes verts qui dit que 40% des
hélicoptères ne veulent pas que les
tanks sont à l'arrêt etc et tout et donc
l'idée si vous voulez de de d'injecter
cette somme considérable de 200
milliards elle est aussi beaucoup vécue
par les allemands comme une forme de
remise à niveau d'une armée qui en gros
depuis la fin de la guerre froide
n'existait quasiment plus donc c'est pas
vécu comme de la
remilitarisation mais voilà plutôt comme
une mise à niveau de ce que doit être
l'armée d'un d'un grand pays d'un grand
pays moderne et je reprends juste une
ce que vous disiez sur les Allemands
peuples Pacifique je pense qu'en fait
c'est une idée c'est une idée reçue
qu'il faut pas qu'il faut pas exagérer
outre mesure récemment je parlais à un
responsable d'une grande étude annuelle
faite sur plusieurs milliers de
personnes un peu sur l'état d'esprit des
Allemands vis-à-vis de la chose
militaire et en fait ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que depuis une
quinzaine d'années tout ce qui est
quelle image avez-vous de l'armée
faut-il investir plus dans l'armée etc
ça monte donc et même sur quelque chose
qui dont on croit souvent que ces tabou
de la part des Allemands c'est à dire ok
on veut bien envoyer des avions au Mali
mais surtout pas tuer un homme surtout
faut que la guerre soit propre
ça évolue en fait ça évolue donc il y a
ce fond pacifiste mais il y a quand même
un traîne une tendance qui montre que
globalement et notamment les jeunes
générations c'est ça qui est vachement
intéressant notamment les jeunes
générations sont peut-être moins
pacifices que les 50 nerfs ou les
sexagénaires qui sont marqués par le
souvenir du nazisme le plus jeune et ça
etc une peut-être une génération plus
réaliste et plus prête justement à
approuver des choix comme celui qui a
fait cholz et nous en tant que Français
on avait la première armée de l'Union
européenne ce sera peut-être plus le cas
maintenant avec cette nouvelle
investissement on doit le voir d'un
bonnet côté français pour davantage de
coopération notamment dans le cadre de
l'Union européenne ça doit on doit
l'avoir pris cette nouvelle comme une
bonne nouvelle c'est intéressant que
vous que vous terminiez par là parce que
effectivement il y a quelques années
quand une phrase comme celle qui a
prononcé le chancelier scholls en disant
avec ses 100 milliards nous allons avoir
la plus grande armée conventionnelle
d'Europe ça aurait donné des des
surfroies là beaucoup de Français qui
pour qui le réarmement allemand
ravivait de de très mauvais souvenirs et
tout ça n'a quasiment pas été commenté
en France en fait cette phrase et je
pense que ça ne l'a pas été même pas
ceux qui cultivent parfois une fibre peu
germanophobe côté Mélenchon ou dans une
droite un peu un peu souverainiste et
nationale on a entendu très très peu de
une action là aussi je pense que c'est
parce que
il y a quand même l'idée que c'était
plutôt la faiblesse militaire et la
faiblesse
géopolitique de l'Allemagne ces
dernières années qui reflète un peu sur
l'Europe qui reflète oui voilà qui
déteignait sur l'Europe et qui était
plus un problème et donc voir
effectivement l'Allemagne avec les
moyens financiers quand même
considérables dont elles dispose pouvoir
aussi participer à cet effort de défense
européenne je pense que côté français
c'est plutôt vu d'un d'un bon œil après
toute la question et là on est qu'au
début du chantier les choses sont sont
pas forcément clair c'est qu'elle va
être vraiment cette défense européenne
parce qu'il y a toujours une sorte d'un
peu d'ambiguïté de malentendus dans le
franco-allemand là-dessus entre une
France qui depuis le général de Gaulle
on va dire a plutôt tendance à penser
que il peut y avoir une forme
d'autonomie en stratégique c'est à dire
le concept utilisé par Emmanuel Macron
et
voir d'autonomie européenne stratégique
et une Allemagne qui depuis la guerre
froide elle considère que tout ce qui
est de l'ordre du militaire ne peut
vraiment se faire que dans le cadre de
l'OTAN et donc là il y aura sans doute
des discussions compliquées mais disons
que sur l'idée d'investir davantage et
sur l'idée d'en faire plus pour la
défense européenne je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui est sur lequel les
Français les Allemands se retrouvent
merci beaucoup Thomas Vedder d'avoir été
avec nous dans une Europe merci je
rappelle que vous êtes donc le
correspondant du journal Le Monde ici à
Berlin français
[Musique]
et on va se détendre à présent pour
finir cette émission la capitale
allemande abrite d'excellents club la
vie nocturne niait très animé alors
plutôt que de vous faire la tournée des
barres je vais vous faire découvrir le
bar yeder verte car la comédie et le
cabaret ont une longue tradition ici à
Berlin et ça remonte au début du 20e
siècle je vous montre le show et on se
retrouve ensuite avec Franziska Kessler
la directrice artistique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Francesca Kessler bonjour Berlin est
connu en Europe pour son monde de la
nuit il n'y a pas trop de difficultés à
remplir la salle quel est votre
stratégie pour avoir plus de spectateurs
spectateurs
le public car tellement de lieux veulent
attirer les gens nous essayons de
proposer des spectacles brillants et oui
je veux dire que notre stratégie est
bien sûr d'abord d'avoir des spectacles
de qualité et on espère ensuite que les
gens en parlent à leurs amis et sur les
réseaux sociaux pour nous amener encore
d'autres personnes nous mettons des
postes et je pense que c'est bien mais
la chose la plus importante reste bouche
à oreille et les réseaux sociaux
maintenant ça compte
décor mais déjà quel décor c'est une
petite scène assez intimiste depuis
quand ce cabaret existe-t-il de cabaret
existe oui
le barillet d'air vers nous est né en 92
donc nous avons fêté nos 30 ans cette
année oui depuis 1992 quel genre de
spectacle peut-on venir voir ici
nous produisons aussi des spectacles
mais principalement des spectacles
musicaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce soir nous avons un spectacle musical
avec des chansons qui évoquent une
personne que personne ne connaît en tout
cas en Allemagne
mais par contre tout le monde connaît
ses musiques il s'appelle frankyvalie
et vraiment tout le monde chante et
connais ses chansons mais personne ne
connaît l'homme derrière ses musiques oh
danse musical donc ce soir c'est une
comédie musicale toujours Francky Valli
avec un groupe qui s'appelle Les Quatre
Saisons donc il y aura de la musique et
de la danse au programme ce soir
[Musique]
vous parlez des artistes justement
certains ont commencé ici dans ce bar
avant de devenir célèbre dans toute
l'Allemagne ce cabaret peut être un
tremplin pour les artistes finally for
artistes
absolument c'est ce que nous sommes
depuis 30 ans
nous avons démarré avec des artistes qui
voulaient juste faire quelque chose ici
ce n'est pas comme un théâtre classique
mais pas non plus comme un cabaret comme
on peut en trouver en Allemagne
c'est un entre deux nous avons inventé
un nouveau genre et dans ce nouveau
genre les gens ont aimé des artistes qui
sont aujourd'hui très connus en
Allemagne et ils ont commencé chez nous
et c'est comme vous l'avez dit un
tremplin
oui
pour les artistes et on permet de
continuer à trouver de nouveaux artistes
et de les faire connaître
avec nous et puis maintenant on va
profiter du spectacle
[Musique]
merci Monsieur pour le show zone Europe
c'est terminé vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission en podcast audio et vidéo
sur notre site internet sur notre
application radio sensation et aussi sur
TV 78 nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro et on
se quitte en musique
[Musique]